[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'élégance d'un esprit libre postin
clapier suit son chemin tracé en
équilibre entre quête de performance et
d'émancipationlé voilà moi j'y suis né
donc j'avais envie aussi j'avais besoin
de mon indépendance de changer
d'environnement et escrimement parlant
bah moi j'étais plus bien dans dans ma
peau là où j'étais
le dilemme que j'avais est-ce que je
pars ou pas c'est est-ce que est-ce que
je vais progresser est-ce que ça va
vraiment être un bon tournant dans
l'escri est-ce que à un an des Jeux
c'est pas trop risqué de tout
changer et d'un autre côté bah j'étais
hyper contente voilàp moi j'ai toujours
rêvé de l'intégrer nouveau décor
l'Institut National du Sport l'INP dans
le bois de Vincen à Paris le cœur du
réacteur du sport français le Graal un
centre d'entraînement avec tout ce dont
un athlète a besoin kiné médecin
psychologue salle de musculation et
l'internat Faustine vit ici depuis 6
mois en colocation avec constance
catarzi elle aussi escririmeuse une
bulle dans la
bulle je t'aime Faustine je t'aime je
l'adore ça se passe si bien oui de fou
c'est c'est fou quoi j'ai une vraie
écologue quoi genre c'est trop bien on
fait les machines on va à la pharmacie
ensemble tu es en contact avec des des
gens qui sont
hyper réputés en dire dans le sport qui
font beaucoup de perffin qui sont un peu
des stars et tout et toi tu es à côté
est-ce que tu as ce côté je me compare
ou est-ce que tu as ce côté waouh je
suis dans la même structure que cette
personne là quand même quoi pour être à
la hauteur de l'institution la jeune
femme s'investit encore plus dans son
sport depuis septembbre elle suit une
licence de psychologie à distance plus
flexible et moins chronophage que ses
études d'Art et de Design à Orléan avant
de me mettre manuellement à mon boulot
il fallait que je trouve un concept il
fallait que je comprenne la consigne il
fallait que je me démarque des autres il
fallait que j'ai le matos que je découpe
des trucs que je colle des trucs que
j'assemble et que ça rende un projet
propre pour le présenter peut-être le
lendemain quoi et ça bah s'il fallait
que j'y passe la nuit fallait que j'y
passe la nuit quoi à l'inep la jeune
orléanaise de 22 ans retrouve la
médaille olympique Cécilia Berder sa
collègue de club à Orléan
elle a un autre jeu aussi très félin sur
une piste de scrim c'est très beau ce
qu' qu'elle propose c'est très propre
c'est très joueur c'est très malin j'ai
pas l'impression qu'elle est jeune en
fait on a vraiment elle a une grande
maturité qui fait qu'on peut vraiment
échanger de tout elle a un humour
décapant à table c'est toujours elle une
capacité à faire des imitations ou à
faire des voilà faut lui demander des
imitations à fausine parce qu'elle est
vraiment incroyable làdessus alors on a
suivi le conseil et on lui a demandé je
peux pas vous faire ça à la télé il
faudrait
que soiré en compétition RZ pas compte
de tous les gens qui pourrai utiliser ça
contre on est dans un monde sans pitié
ici
apparemment le groupe vit bien pourtant
toutes ces filles sont là pour la même
chose représenter la France aux Jeux
Olympiques l'été prochain les
partenaires d'entrainement de Faustine
sont aussi ses premières concurrentes
ses
rivales c'est rassurant de s'entraîner
dans une nation aussi forte et qui a
autant d'avenir ça veut dire qu'on est
au bon endroit et d'un autre côté c'est
dur de d'entre guillemets se comparer à
ces fillesl pour essayer d'aller
chercher leur place l'INSEP c'est donc
l'Institut national du sport mais on
pourrait aussi l'appeler la maison
Faustine s sent déjà comme chez elle
elle prévoit de vivre ici pour façonner
son corps et son esprit jusqu'au jeu de
Los Angeles en 2028 du talent une
structure un équilibre ici Faustine a
tout pour devenir une grande et ça tombe
bien elle entend bien en être une
commence à être impatiente quoi à me
dire c'est long ça prend du temps et moi
j'ai envie de les rattraper maintenant
tout de suite quoi les jeux ils arrivent
et et je veux je veux sentir qu'il y a
du progrès que ça avance que que je
fournis du bon travail
mais mais en fait vaut mieux que le
temps il apporte quelque chose de
qualitatif plutôt que de se précipiter
et d'avoir quelque chose de de taux mais
qui soit pas dans la durée là je me sens
bien dans ma tête et dans mon corps euh
peut-être qu'il y aura des BAT peut-être
que ça va rester comme ça peut-être que
je vais stagner il y aura des
frustrations il y aura des récompenses
du travail Forni mais pour l'instant je
me sens bien et et surtout je me sens
bien dans le choix que j'ai fait de
venir ici D